this is Betty does a lot to take in
Jory's got her hambo um hold on to
that might be the only way you chef seen
her at the end of this you it's just
like oh no I'm tough
no I don't care really I was like the
whole god I mean if it really is so much
the process um and okay let's just start
from the beginning uh Bella Notte the
big bad magic entity dark magic anti
magic whatever is a five finally brought
in and he's sucking out all the Wizards
magic and that includes the Ice King and
Ice King goes right back to Simon I mean
I even like really I'm gonna bring up so
this has been kind of slowly building
the whole Bella Notte thing but if you
remember during the Wizards Only Fools
they showed the diagram of abracadaniel
being killed sacrificed for this to
happen
so does this mean abracadaniel is dead
yeah oh my god I don't know maybe if you
remember they were taught the they all
this has been slowly building yeah every
other episode they found like a little
clue doing yeah even the hambo thing I
think or no though they tree bambo right
okay well yeah the one where they're
going in there and then there's the
Brigadier
the ice King's invisible and they're
said they're talking about killing
abracadabra fighting him they work did
they kill him he might be dead we don't
see him again we'll know why so so so
Simon is back and he and he has all his
marbles there and he he goes to his ice
kingdom any contacts Marci letting her
know just very quickly that I need to
make this this time portal to go back
into
I am and tell my wife goodbye she passes
out you know from and then gets back up
and says you know okay we got to do this
so and hambo is the key gives it
something held onto for a long time and
a lot love for it so they use that to
get a portal to go to his wife Betty and
while he's going crazy in the past and
originally saying goodbye but then she
jumps through the portal and says I'm
gonna find a way to save you because
you're growing older and dying really
quickly the age is catching up so she
goes and defeats Bella Notte and says
that she's gonna find some loophole in
the crown to to save him and she does I
she defeats him Bella Notte
blows up icing is his crown back all the
magic is back and ice Kings backs to his
normal self I mean barely remembers
anything um if he does remember anything
it just remembers what people told him
afterwards and you see his wife looking
through the window and she flies off
which fiance right that's right that's
right
um his princess yes so yeah I guess it
is kind of like already even start with
it um the whole I think pretty solidly
the first two-thirds of this I mean I
was kind of like you I was like oh I
mean I really like just all this all
this info in eleven minutes and all
those emotions being thrown at you so
fast and it's surprisingly like hitting
me in all of these and you know sort of
unlike unlike the one where Simon was
with Marcy as a little kid you see him
fighting off the jelly donut zombies and
stuff
it is something something about like I
didn't know where this one was going and
like the minute you saw him is Simon I
was like whoa and when it just kept
going out just amazed at how much
they're throwing at us and outlet for
the most part at least for me
emotionally it was kind of working uh
but I'll be honest I didn't I didn't
fully get the end because she said she
would find a loophole that why does she
fly away them to go find the loophole
she's got to do something well what
would it be course know who she is both
and care who she is so it's not like she
has to be
she doesn't have to be with him too
fix him she just she doesn't not
necessarily not if she's doing some sort
of loophole thingamajiggy okay I mean I
thought it was gonna be like whatever
look on the crown or do some test with
them because he's kind of the subject
that has to be changed I wouldn't make
sense to be around the subject to try
experimenting and stuff I mean that was
Beth she's in the research phase in
which case if she's traveling ooh well
what you need the crown to researcher no
not necessarily
do you need a gun to research about guns
I mean do what help the NRA says I know
you could read up on it you could talk
to people about their experiences with
it I mean maybe she's just gathering her
information first before she goes back
to him to work on the crown maybe you
don't want to tinker with it and so
you'd know everything you think you
possibly could know about it I guess but
I don't can she talk to Ben and Jake or
could she uh it seems like there's a lot
of stuff she could do there you know
even like just befriending it even she's
like hi I'm princess fiance or whatever
oh god let's hang out I mean it's like
there's a lot of things you could do to
still be around and then it's like hey
could you take the crown the first I got
yeah Cheryl can I look at yeah sure
that's what are you doing oh just look
at it through a microscope you know
whatever I mean it's like there's stuff
she could do I think I oughta for me I
didn't get why she had to leave you know
necessarily um especially for a
scientist as someone who seems pretty
damn smart and picked up all this stuff
really fast and saved the day and that's
my issue with this episode actually know
that she left at the end no no no that
that I understand again it felt like
this was closing chapters like almost
like the series was afraid that it might
have get might get cancelled they're
closing as many chapters as possible
before the end of this season which is
it cuz again why are we all sin bringing
her back and then she's instantly
disappearing but the Ice King is normal
it's kind of like yeah I guess it worked
now my problem is and this happens in
movies and TV shows all the damn time
some modern kid from our time gets
teleported back to will say you know
medieval times and also is able to
master
sting in the sword in a matter of a
couple days really or someone from those
times coming to our time and is able to
master driving a car a couple days I'd
be lying if I said that wasn't kind of
on my mind
noise the hell out of me that and I know
it's a minor thing but in this episode
you have Betty someone from our time is
also able to jump through some portal
without questioning it and then is able
to fly a magic carpet without even
questioning it
notice exactly pretty much where to go
for the weakness of this giant monster
that well let's see the giant uh hair
colored covered guy knew who that was
but somehow could not figure out how to
defeat it
but someone who's not even remotely from
that time or doesn't know anything about
magic no she was thinking inside the box
again this is I could totally be making
excuses for the show you are by probably
up but the fact that they were both they
were both scientists and they were both
studying the same thing they're studying
the crown and stuff I mean they and he
was starting to go loopy while putting
the crown on and stuff I mean you could
argue maybe she was already starting to
study that stuff and figure out about it
just because you start studying one form
of science doesn't mean you understand
all forms of science ain't true okay why
did you know two plus two does not mean
you know long division the two Biggie's
for me are the the magic carpet and the
going inside the Bella Notte and
defeating him like yet how would you
know exactly air color covered guy
although he was going you could say the
Bell knows anything she was just lucky
like she was riding than the carpet got
zapped and she was just crawling in just
looking for something if you happen to
stumble cross you won't argue that why
could none of these wizards do the same
thing maybe they don't have a magic
carpet well maybe they don't to obsessed
with their magic and that's the only way
they know how to do it could be or maybe
the writers just needed Betty to come in
and save the day to wrap it up I mean
probably no no no I think I think I
don't think they could see beyond magic
because their whole lives are wrapped
around magic but shouldn't they know how
to defeat a magical or non- magical
being without magic
maybe not he said throw your boots at
him and they did it he was trying
exactly but that's my issue I hate when
movies and TV shows and stuff do that no
you need to learn spend at least a year
a week a month in this time period
before you know how to master a magic
freaking carpet I mean granted they only
have 11 minutes you know but at the same
time it is kind of like I was thinking
that too Abbi I was an idiot carpet
maybe it was an automatic but I did like
the fact that he came back though Sam
Lewis and Oh God was it a sh Marceline's
X X the one who had the carpet yeah up
briefs giving me apparently the
thumbs-up also what bothered me about
this episode was the whole hambo thing a
couple episodes ago we had bubble up
bubble gum giving up something
incredibly important to get back hambo
boom ham was already gone it felt like
that episode was almost all for naught
no I doesn't know I disagree because
that that was the object now something's
supposed to be kept around and had like
the most love and something that the
that they connected with that was going
to help him travel back in time to say
goodbye and if she didn't go through all
of that you could argue that loved one
of them as strong for that dawn the
thing would have worked so I think it
was building up exactly to this to him
going back and saying goodbye mm-hmm
that's my excuse
yeah no I actually I can see it from
your perspective and I'm not saying
you're wrong but
IIIi would like to yes but I can't cuz
yeah you're probably right
at least at this point in time damn um
but now with all the stuff that you
pointed out that you didn't like did you
did you like the episode or not really
again it felt incredibly rushed and it
there were parts I did like but I don't
know it it just felt incredibly rusty
you know it it did feel rushed I mean I
can act like it it didn't feel that way
but I think what made this work for me
and not in the last episode that felt
they threw a lot of stuff in really
quick and it didn't add up was that even
though a lot of stuff was being thrown
at you with the exception for picking up
all the magic and technology and stuff
oh yeah everything seemed to hit
everybody appropriately like when
Marceline heard the news like if she's
just past that I mean that's a perfect
reaction I'm like how she gonna react to
this oh what'd you see or passed out
it's like yep that makes perfect sense
uh when you see her saying goodbye the
hambo and so I mean it's like that makes
perfect sense it's not like here you go
and it's nothing you know she really
looks and says okay and knows what it's
for when you see the wife you're leaving
me well who'd you leave me for it's just
like I know that you're dumping me no no
it's not like that just time is running
out and stuff eh yeah you know and she's
like you know I Know Who I look before
who you know what she jumps through it's
like it's quick but you get it it's like
yeah you can see her kind of doing that
so I don't know
see if let's say I went to the bathroom
and I'm in the toilet Nelson something
opens up in front of me and it's Jory
that's like here's what's gonna happen
no sir no no no okay imagine jury is out
here with some crazy as crowds turning
everything to Isaac I'll kill you I'll
kill you I'll kill you
Singh where's my Betty wears white
prints what'll zapping everything while
killing every Thursday night Thursday's
is nobody's invited over things those
Facebook parties were where nobody was
invited just to stay away no advance on
invitation okay that seems too quick in
my opinion to just kind of accept it as
fact instead as a scientist or something
I would expect her to be a little bit
more questioning of what the heck's
going on like huh a teleport uh a rift
into like time and space has now opened
up in front of me oh this is interesting
Oh jump through it no questions asked no
no but you saw the earth see that's why
like you saw the urgency of how quickly
he was saying it but still how focus and
determined oh this is what happened and
time is fading I'm so sorry I got to
blah blah blah while the other him is
going crazy and at this point it's like
why not believe him I mean you know and
they've been studying this thing as well
and they know about it it's in a strange
way for all the crazy stuff that's been
happening it kind of made sense I guess
the I guess what it is is that she's
like you're breaking up with me really
you just said you're your man is out
there going ballistic shooting things
but he just told you right now he's a
thousand years in the future and that's
what you're gonna say and blindly jump
into a portal why not but again this
stuff is happening so quick and so fast
that I don't even think it's like you
know the stuff doesn't even have total
time to process it's just you hear it
and then you throw a question back I
don't know Jordan bonkers you know
shooting ice everywhere I wouldn't jump
into a portal with some woman that
looked like her
nobody loser how where was the proof in
the pudding what just because it looks
like her
it's going to animate bid well no this
is gonna be just gonna be after it's
probably given or it might be during I
don't know no shame pudding the thing is
is in this world and make it wet
Adventure Time in this world of
adventure time we have already seen that
things can imitate other things it's
happened every once in a while and then
in our modern time if a portal opened up
in front of me what's on that looked
like Jory when Jory was out here I'd be
a little bit questionable about just
jumping into an L gate number with the
MIT Jory behind
okay okay with the information that your
door he said like Simon said there
though would you know it was Jory no no
oh you ran away from me giving me more
than he would assign me that's true I
would that would make more than Simon
all he said was you left me and he never
came back that hadn't happened like yeah
all he did all she did was run away
that's all the information all the in
stone information that he gave her
nothing like back in our anniversary of
when we dated 34 years ago okay that I
can accept no buy me like the tonot I
don't know I you just would jump at any
random portal that your wife was in
one even though she was in another room
she was I'm this one is gonna be given
quizzes pop pop quiz oh yeah you stay
with your crazy wife and your weird
Thursday night games or whatever I'm
gonna jump in the porno with my same
rational wife and keep back in time to
get me and that's really cool thanks
honey
thanks for doing that but you're gonna
leave your crazy one behind I see how
you are because I'm gonna see her in the
future she's gonna be sane
yeah but you're not gonna hook the one
right now that you'd rather nah I'm
gonna throw the caring and the love and
beam by marriage and there's the other
proof so you know he said that you know
I forgive you for leaving me except she
put together that's why I left that's
how I left and that's why she went in
the portal see it makes sense yes it's
it's not an excuse to like leave your
wife Doug disappears what happened so
Arab Alexis I just like old people and
kids you are horrible I you would stay
with your crazy
zap yes because you've seen my wife for
worse I but you know that she's gonna be
banned in the future as can this wait
okay no no because it's you I know what
happened you jumped through the portal
because you in a little portal but he
said you disagree like a stuffed animal
so except that yeah yeah yeah are you
fine yes I love you you suck so say what
you thought say what you thought I
I think things and also stuff I can't
help you don't look at me it's not like
so that's a but you got more than that
come on come on Maura
you barely said thing come on I am still
processing but I thought it was I know I
don't know I love you too I was busy
laughing at you although to be fair to
be fair and not because I'm a horrible
person I mean I am I just feel like she
jumped in just because I don't know it's
I feel like maybe you would know you
just would know she just knew that that
was her assignment and it was like okay
great there's hope over here so let's
let's work together in the future to
hopefully fix the past I think a lot of
it too is like Doug said I mean it's all
this all this stuff happening all at
once it's a bunch of crazy
I can't think and it's not even going
insane around here like I just hear a
little bit of noise and I'm like oh
can't think shut up and I just I just
feel like she made a split-second
decision is it that great I mean maybe
maybe not but it she made a decision and
she's doing whatever she can I guess I'm
a little caught up in the characters I
can't like I mean I'm just I'm not
seeing Jason's reaction as far as well
you know they're trying to tie up loose
ends and stuff I don't feel like they're
trying to tie up loose ends at all I
just feel like this is where the story
is going sometimes I'm interested and
sometimes I'm not and with this one I
was really interested I really although
I'm wondering why he likes Betty so much
she doesn't seem like a very sweet lady
at all
no she kind of kicks ass she jumped
through the portal and is trying to save
him she's going literally through hills
and valleys and climbing in this thing
and kicking ass and stuff and gonna
dedicate her life to try to find a way
to bring him back and that's not a sweet
lady there's there's something to be
said for being an ass kicked
awesome ass woman but I don't know I
just pour your man I know but just a
little I missed you how are you doing
did you see this episode pretty much
fair world I don't know they say it's
just getting rid of magic that's all I
was doing
yeah that's like a world yeah a huge no
no but you know he's getting rid of
Simon and Simon is her world okay I'll
give you that
yeah no you guys are tending to forget
the one important thing that happened in
this episode
what did death sing oh yeah what do you
say he says you lose something right is
that the assignment is like gone like he
has Simon well he said you will be the
Ice King till the Sun explodes yeah and
he says this is your last chance yeah
and as he starts turning right as he's
about to turn back into Ice King he says
you lose Simon yeah so the idea is that
he until the Sun explodes he's always
gonna be ice gay yep yeah okay so he's
like well remember what even from the
beginning it's like the more he wears it
the deeper and deeper he goes until he's
done I don't get why she went off I I
can guess why why would you it it kind
of to me goes back to the whole
Alzheimer's thing how could you be
around someone that you love so deeply
and that loved you so deeply but was
wouldn't even recognize you you know
what I like this well you know I would
that would be so hard breaking a more
heartbreaking than being away from that
person where you can rest remember the
past instead of having to be almost kind
of slapped in the face each time I was
gonna say that I I wouldn't mind maybe
an episode right after this where she
comes to that conclusion trying to you
move with him at each and then she goes
away but the more thing might that'd
probably be too similar to the one with
Marceline and remembering and stuff yeah
so it's that be tricky to do it they
were
do that ricky-ricky um yeah so uh I like
to I just like to see it as she went off
because she's gonna go try and do I
don't know the equivalent the equivalent
of chicken webmd.com remember you
ordered the hit man
yeah that's Jake answers questions
that's right yeah so it means you can't
look at me I don't know
but yeah I still liked it even though it
was a lot and was throwing you very fast
I thought sort of the the emotional hits
still felt right it still felt like even
though a lot of stuff was happening is
happening quick the way B reacted is how
they would react and it was still
emotionally satisfying for me even
though I agree they throw a lot where
the last one they threw a lot it seemed
to happen very slowly in an odd way and
the emotional it's didn't add up I felt
this one they I felt they had I thought
they did pretty good
the only other question I have it was an
OK episode I liked it for what it was it
was okay but the other question I have
is Ice King I liked when he was coming
back and he's like you know even my
sanity insanity he finds his glasses
but then he shoves that thing aside and
inside is this completely organized
completely well put together like the
like a library I was in laboratory and
he's got his jacket there and everything
he's I go look at my coat and all that
stuff it's like but when did he build
that well yeah it doesn't seem like
something he built or had years and
years and years and years ago because it
seems to be part of this ice Kingdom
he's built unless it was unless this ice
tower has been there for years and years
and years but we saw him in the middle
of the street already losing his crap oh
it makes me wonder but maybe it was
maybe it was just him for a while in the
beginning losing it and coming back and
losing it and coming back that's not
what I'm saying cuz it kind of looked
like his where
kept everything in the holiday like
secrets in the video and you sort of saw
things encased and stuff but they were
just now encased in ice yeah you sort of
look like the same set up though so
that's possible that's one thing with
joy like maybe he kept going in and
going back or maybe if the writers are
watching we just gave them a way to
explain mean no charge
yeah all right they'll be oh like six
bucks seven bucks that's really really I
get percent damnit percentages really
yes and you get nothing means they don't
even feed me do you people understand
they don't even know yeah we're getting
we gave you a seat you chose the floor
there you why do I scare you
why do I scare you wait there's a portal
over there of yourself
quick jump into it hey that's the toilet
I hope he's gone forever wait come on
loan again ah Jason help me I'm from the
future
I say no cuz you're upside down